the bottom line is washington hates you
some of you might be wondering stephen
why are you talking about our government
i thought you covered scams
that would be my answer i do cover scams
that's why we're talking about the
coveted relief bill
remember they told you hey when covet
hit they said we're not going to leave
you guys behind because we're massively
incompetent you know we're going to take
care of you we're going to pass
these stimulus checks you're going to
get money in your pocket and you know
what
small businesses we're not going to let
you fail right we got the ppp
for you and look how well that turned
out joel olsteen's getting a 4.4 million
dollar kick back but don't worry he
needs it he's a small
up-and-coming pastor kanye west little
tiny shoe company
he needs the ppp to stay alive it
doesn't matter which side of the
spectrum you're on listen mitch
mcconnell called this a historic relief
bill what's historic about it
pete you're getting 600 bucks that's
what they're giving you you know what
nancy pelosi says
about it she says it's a significant
amount to america's working families
they are uh significant a significant
amount
this lady's so out of touch listen she
got into politics in 1987. six hundred
dollars wasn't even a significant amount
back then but you're expected to take
this lying down
all the while that this thing is so
stuffed with pork that the baconator's
jealous
listen guys out of the 900 trillion
dollars that's being spent in this thing
hey you're getting 18 of it where's the
rest of the money go well
a lot of it goes to the ppp program
remember we need kanye west and joel
olsteen to get more money where the
other part of this goes is detailed in a
5 000 page document that nobody
has read not me not anybody in the house
or the senate but rest assured guys
it's important it's it's important stuff
guys like uh
10 million dollars for gender programs
in pakistan that's the kind of stuff
that's getting passed
in a coveted belt and listen you can be
a fan of gender programs in pakistan but
this has less to do with coping
than the furniture stimulus that was
also passed oh that's right
you see these guys right here these two
people who are supposedly on different
sides of the aisle yeah
they need new furniture guys you guys
understand that right they never let a
good pandemic go to waste ladies and
gentlemen
they've allotted themselves hmm how much
is that 89
million dollars for furniture for the
senate
are you joking i'm pretty sure you could
buy an iron throne for each of the
senators with that kind of money and
still have money left over these people
hate you i'm telling you this is why i
don't get political in my show guys i
don't go left or right because if you
bat for one side of the team you can't
criticize the game
and the game is you get royally screwed
and they get royal thrones to sit on
with their 89 million dollars for
furniture
now among other things in this bill what
else do we got here what else
guys well these geniuses in washington
have uh officially made their policies
on the succession
and reincarnation of the dalai lama
clear which thank god for that we were
all worried uh we all might die from a
pandemic if we didn't figure out the
succession of the dalai lama
it's pages long by the way guys the
constitution
four pages long one stimulus check
that's a no-brainer that should have
been passed months ago
hey 5 000 pages
oh it's beyond parody to give you guys
an idea of how much
how far 900 billion dollars could have
gone
let's just say they gave this straight
to the american people let's say they go
hey the ppp
that was a massive mistake corruption
everywhere the money's going to the
wrong people it's not going to the small
businesses like they say they are
you know you have people like atlantic
diving supply still qualifying as
small businesses with over a billion
dollars in revenue
that's a total joke so if you just gave
it to the american people
instead of getting a 600 check every
single person would be getting a 3 200
check and listen if you've been out of
work
for the last i don't know nine months
that's not even that much that's not
gonna save your life like
congress is acting like 600 is all of a
sudden gonna build a lifeboat and to
give anything more would be
you know oh my gosh they don't need that
that's ridiculous dude people are so far
behind 3 200
is a drop in the bucket and it's the
least you can do but instead we're more
worried about giving 130 million dollars
to nepal or 453 million dollars
to ukraine listen i already saved
ukraine okay
my my designer can tell you we're
wasting money on things like
a billion dollars to the smithsonian or
40 million dollars to the kennedy center
154 million dollars
to the national art gallery and look i
love art as much to the next guy
but i'm pretty sure having access to the
number one 1950 by jackson pollock
isn't the biggest priority on everyone's
list now all of this
insanity has led up to maybe the most
surprising thing of all uh
donald trump making some sense on
twitter
i'm asking congress to amend this bill
and increase the ridiculously low
six hundred dollars to two thousand
dollars
or four thousand dollars for a couple
i'm also asking congress to immediately
get rid of the wasteful and unnecessary
items
from this legislation now i know a lot
of people are just going to say hey this
is just political theater which
sure probably is uh but it doesn't make
it any less true you know things can be
true even if they come out of the mouth
of a guy that you like you dislike it
doesn't make the statement
any less true congress needs to get rid
of these ridiculous
amendments to this what should be a
straightforward bill you know
get relief into the hands of the
american people that you
forced to shut down their businesses you
know the government forced
to shut down their shops so we could all
you know chip in for each other for this
pandemic
but all of a sudden when it comes down
to giving you money you're left holding
the bill
and instead sudan and burma end up with
all the money
while these two are left trying to fist
bump i guess
these people are an embarrassment
anyways i just wanted to cover that
because
it's just a historic level of scam
artistry
going on at the highest levels of
government meanwhile you're getting
shafted
and i wanted to document it guys because
this this channel we cover scams that's
what we do
and this bill this covid relief bill
it's a scam it's covered relief
in name only thanks for watching see you
guys next time
comes along